when i went through his phone thought he
was sleeping
then he turned around and said after
you've finished finding out what you're
looking for
go cry outside
okay right guys this is episode 101
we're about so i'm sure all of you guys
are keen to know what's going on with
the mission 1k now that it's been
completed
yeah mom um so again guys thank you so
much
um you made the dreams come true never
thought was going to happen
um but i actually did um
and then yeah it was very cool
very cool of you guys um we really
appreciate it
yeah man you man pulled out all the
stops for us so thank you yeah yeah
thank you very much
you went in you went in you went in um
and you stayed going in so guys
here's it is we
will be starting the
two episodes a week starting from
beginning of august so from beginning of
august onwards you guys will be getting
two episodes a week
now here's the kicker here's the kicker
here's the kicker
hold on to your seats guys hold on two
seats
we're going to be releasing episodes on
mondays and thursdays so look out
mondays and thursdays is where you're
going to be getting your episodes
episode on thursday is going to be
patreon only
you must have known this was coming you
have to you must have known
that this this was going to be this was
this was the deal we we're not going to
sit here and let next man pay for your
contest
that we couldn't let that fly that's a
disservice to all these men that ran in
and helped us hit the mission 1k in the
first place patrons are the ones that
got us there so the patrons
patrons are going to be the ones that
benefit so mondays
for youtube and audio um
spotify whatever thursdays will be for
the patrons
let's run it back mondays and thursdays
youtube patrons you know what it is
um now you know what you need to do if
you want to be
scooping up more every episode if you
want to scoop up every episode you
already it's going to cost you three
pound a month
you already know that you you've been
knowing that you can
tell your weekend if you want the sauce
three pound a month
um on top of that guys
as much as would love to do you dirty
and that's just be
it we've got a little something for you
as well we've got a new segment that's
going to be starting
um either the first week or the second
week potentially of
august which is going to be our new
segment talking [ __ ]
so talking [ __ ] is going to come out i
don't know what day it's going to come
out yet we haven't actually discussed
this
we haven't decided what day is going to
come out but so that you don't feel too
disheartened
guys technically speaking you're still
going to get two episodes a week on
youtube so you've got your main episode
um with obviously me and fou had
uh on your monday and then on thursdays
we're going to be doing a guest segment
every say thursday we just said we don't
even know
the other day that it comes out your
second episode of the week
it's going to be a little bit shorter
guest segment
from all different walks of life it's
going to be a lot of fun guys
um and the the method behind the madness
is that we know sometimes you guys want
to see guests
some of you guys don't want to see
guests so before we do best of both
so that if you enjoy the episodes but
you don't like when we have guests
at least it's not going to ruin it for
you and you don't have to look at the
talking [ __ ]
but if you do want guest guys you get to
tune in to talk and [ __ ] and if you're
so basically if you're a patreon you get
three episodes a week from now there you
go
um this is how it's going to boogie um
so guys thank you again
we appreciate you we always do this has
been dope um
and then we just need to figure out what
the next goal is now i guess it's
mission 2k i was just about to say we
need to get to 2k now yeah but now we
need to get to 2k
you guys yeah yeah yeah that is
the field really quick i was just about
to say big man
i can really quit car you know me i
speak to you every day but you man i'm
tired yeah first of all you wanna stay
tight who has exhausted bro i'm burning
the candle at both ends so yeah
i met him that he was asleep i left me
getting sunburned outside he wouldn't
let me in
he was asleep guys he's burning the
candle at both ends you need to get him
out
you need to it's long um but mission 1k
was a big start guys so thank you again
appreciate i didn't think it would come
this quick um but it has it's taken its
time but it's also been very quite
very fast as well yeah yeah like we were
saying before
before we start before we hit record um
you were happy to get just 100 pound a
month
and now we're on over a grand a month
you know that's um that's a huge feat so
yeah once again thank you very much guys
you guys are the tips and yeah man just
keep rocking
cool man um so before we get into it
properly
you just said about the my hero oh yeah
so
yes yes yes yes i have started watching
the new season
bro you know what jacob was actually
wrong oh of course
the season's actually decent of course
he was wrong because when i was watching
i was thinking
obviously he put in a group chat that oh
my hero is dead and i was thinking no
he's actually dead but like
the anime's dead and i was thinking is
he talking about the music because i
hadn't seen the new season
put that in there yeah yeah yeah yeah
maybe i was thinking he was just he had
never seen it before and was just
bingeing through
oh he is talking about the new season
i'm thinking now bro
it's not dead at all i think he wants
arm's house from episode one he wants
beef from episode one to episode 16. he
wants beef and i'm like
you have to build up today yeah i was i
was content
maybe i don't know maybe i enjoyed it
more because i thought it was gonna be
[ __ ]
and it's actually not [ __ ]
i see a little bit where he's coming
from in terms of like it's not
core story it's not core story
development you know what i mean
it's like within the school them still
learning a few things here and there but
still bro
it's hype it's hard the the scraps
between class a and class b were heavy
heavy bro
they were heavy are you up to at the
moment because i'm up to date right so
spoiler alert guys get ready
uh if you're my hero fan and you don't
want any spoilers and you haven't caught
up on the new season yet then shut up
i'm on the episode where i said shut up
i don't actually didn't mean to say
i'm not even like turtle same way yeah
she didn't even mean to say that but
yeah same way sharp
um so i'm up to
where [ __ ] where am i up to i'm up to
where
have you seen all the scraps a versus b
yes okay so deca was the last crap right
yes i've seen that
okay so i saw my man lose control with
the team yeah yeah yeah
and uh he tried to control it and all
that yeah
yeah um and
i think that's where i've left it they
had their
um they told my man he's passed and he's
in the hero course now
mm-hmm um and he's vexed because he's
just not good enough yeah the eyes were
contendant party yeah yeah yeah yeah
double ganga
um i've seen toddler rocky use his hot
hot
that was sick hell sick um that was the
time he was about to
use it and then he just went uh bro um
but um one thing i will say is
i'm not entirely sure how i feel
about um
one for all now having different layers
to all this thing
okay does that make sense it does make
sense but why
because
because it then it it kind of makes me
feel like
what is it then so basically okay
cool so it reminds me of um
do you remember heroes the show heroes
yes i don't remember it but i remember
the show but i don't remember like so
much context
yeah so in heroes yeah you had
peter petrelli yeah rings i don't know
how i remember his name peter
who could take people's powers
yeah and as he started to develop he
could hold on to them a bit longer and
use a couple of yeah
at the same time but then you had i
can't remember his name
it was like cipher or something the
other guy that was obsessed with clocks
he could cut people's brains out and
take their powers forever
that was the bad yeah the bad guy yeah
yeah his face in my head coming up
yeah he also plays are like spock in the
star trek movie
yes yeah yeah yeah so there was those
two
and that's basically one for all for one
essentially the same [ __ ] but
now i thought one for all
was so armed because of because it was a
combination of
all these different people and all these
different quirks which is why you're so
rapid and
and like powerful and all this stuff but
now it's like
okay so we're unlocking the individual
users old powers
so it kind of contradicts it doesn't
contradict but it's almost like
oh it's you're so fast and so wham
but the drawback is you need to be tough
enough to handle it
but now it's like oh you you also get
this extra [ __ ] on top
where it's like okay so what's the
drawback to that
you know what i mean i hear you but i
also think
the reason why i won it took so long for
us to figure out that this was even a
thing because
when he or he originally had a um
like a vision of it in the
initial um academy games when you got
brainwashed right
yeah yeah the same guy when you're the
same guy like season three away yeah
yeah
but we didn't know what it was he didn't
know what it was he just saw her and
then we never saw it again until season
five
so i think it's a case of he had to
reach a specific
strength or specific amount of power to
even unlock
this this thing where he can
see into the past or see the other um
previous one for all users
before he can use their their quirks
stuff because obviously he's only used
um all mice one and the guy with the
whips so far whereas there's four
four or four or five other more one for
all users that he hasn't even
yeah yeah yeah yeah i get that but now i
just feel like
he's i just i just feel like with
i just feel like basically one for all
is op as it is
we've now he's gonna potentially develop
like five other quirks
on top of it i just think you're
you're too wham as as is but
but i feel like it's expected purely
because he
we already know he's destined to be the
number one superhero yeah that's the
journey
yeah yeah but we also have never seen
all might use certain things he's only
ever used the smash
because that's that's what he likes to
use yeah yeah so and we've only
we've seen him fight maybe a handful of
times whereas before um
uh what's his name before deca was even
introduced to the thing all might could
have been
doppy and guys with different type of
quirks and different but they never
showed us that purely because
they wanted it no he never did he said
oh my said to deku he ain't got a clue
what this is oh yeah that's true he said
none
he never chatted to none of the past
people
he said he had one dream where he saw
them and that was
it that's true he doesn't know what this
[ __ ] is he's never experienced it his
master's never experienced it
no one's ever experienced it it's true i
forgot about that and the only reason
deku's experience is because my man with
the black [ __ ]
told him you're the one you're the one
that's going to bring all of this
out which i mean get it fair enough
but i just feel it's like um i could
understand
if they were doing this because let's
say deku had already got to 100
in like season two and now we've just
had two three seasons
of him boss and [ __ ] and was getting
boring so they bring
this extra [ __ ] in but man's only on
like twenty percent
yeah so he we ain't seen [ __ ] yet and
all of a sudden now he's got all this
other stuff to do
and i'm like i ain't even seen his best
yet i don't want to introduce it yet i
want to see him get to his full
potential but i don't
i don't think any of those are going to
come in this season maybe the whipped
thing that he did this season is going
to
yeah yeah at the end of the season but
like you said we saw
endeavor a handful of times up until now
season five and
speaking of enderpea i think he is
so op is crazy like he's live
he back when um all might was all my and
he was running singing and he was number
one here and ended
was number two it made me real now
watching season five it made me realize
they both want the same thing but they
have different walks of life yeah
all mike was the guy that wanted to
always do everything with a smile in his
face yeah
endeavor just wanted to get [ __ ] done
yeah yeah because he knew what he had to
do he had to get strong
he had to fight people out to win and he
had to rescue people that's all he knew
he didn't care who he hurt like in terms
of like his family and stuff like that
he just knew that boom i have to save
people and this is do or die
this is literally do or die so don't
come to me with your attitude thinking
i'm stink purely because i'm trying to
save lives
he is obviously you're not up to that
bit yet but
you would just just the way he portrays
himself you it makes you understand why
he is the way he is
yeah yeah yeah i get it and it's just
like oh
i understand why you've been in the
shadow of oh my so long and i'm so happy
he's number one now
yeah yeah yeah yeah i get it i get it
i get it i get it i get it um
he's sighted i can see yeah i he's a
sick guy
but i think i'll tell you what it is i
think that's what my frustration is
going back to the the deku with the new
powers and stuff
i think that's what my frustration is is
because
you with people like endeavour you know
he's been
through it he's been through it and i
think
part of what i like about my hero is
that
perfect example is le million right
mm-hmm obviously you know what his quirk
is and stuff like that
but part of the beauty of him is
realizing
what how much training he's gone through
to make that
random quirk that everyone thought was
[ __ ] he wanted to be a hero
so he spent a big portion of his life
figuring out how he can turn this quirk
into something sick
yeah and he's done it
the beauty of for me the beauty of
deku's quirk one for all
um part of the beauty of it is that just
like lemelion
he's got a sick quirk but he needs to
grind to figure out how he can make it
sick because he's killing himself trying
to he can't use it
so he's having to figure out all these
different methods of how he can actually
make it decent yeah
um so there's so many drawbacks so
like the the good thing about it for me
the show
is that everyone has their own quirk
that has its own drawbacks
so depending on who they fight yeah
they're gonna come into so many
different issues yeah and even endeavour
can't get so hot without [ __ ] himself
over and stuff like that so
all these different things are what make
the show cool to me
but when you take deku with this
opie quirk as it is
like he's gonna face people that
that's not necessarily an issue that's
like they can patent things around that
they can use things to slow him down
they can do this and do that
it's gonna annoy me looking forward if
he faces someone that's
quite op if they
figure out a way to deal with
one for all the way we'd know it yeah
and then he's like
okay cool good thing i got these whips
yeah
do you know what i mean yeah then i'm
like what's the point yeah
so what my man's just never gonna face
adversity
every time like it's just like he's
he's sick enough as it is like like you
take back ago
he started off with his one quirk if you
take him from like season one to where
he's that
now yeah without one quirk you're like
wow
he's fight he's a a versus b fight back
ago has
he's come he's come a long way
his character development has been a one
that fight was amazing amazing
[ __ ] amazing considering the
character he is yeah and the kind of
person he portrays himself to be
wow so i enjoy watching people
take what god's given them well like
as far as this show is this show for me
a lot of it is enjoying the fact that
like life gives you lemons
and all these men are making their own
different flavors of lemonade yeah and
you're like
[ __ ] how did he take that into this yeah
and even back ago like you said it was a
sick quirk to begin with
but now he's taking it to places where
man even man are just like
raw yeah you had a sick quirk yeah but
bro you're on
stuff you're on crud now you want staff
now
whereas deku's lemonade is just going to
be
different [ __ ] all the time and it's
like for me
it's a it's cool it's still cool but a
little bit for me it's a little bit like
like hmm i do hear that
but then again we don't know what's
going to happen obviously we don't know
the kind of
um adversities he's going to face in
like season six or whatever yeah
yeah that's true he might not even be
able to use that [ __ ] you know so you
never know but yeah i was a little bit
like
but i hear that i do hear what you're
saying i didn't think about it that way
because i was just gassed yeah i saw it
and i was just gassed yeah of course
it's a sick concept don't get me wrong
it's a sick concept
i wouldn't mind the thing is i think the
reason
i don't like it is because of how
opie the quirk is
so let's just say all my
had super strength and that's all he had
yeah but up to the level of not one for
all level
but let's just say one for all was just
super strength up to like
40 percent okay and that's all he could
do
so he's now on like a backup guy level
where he's taking that 40
and he's become number one hero because
he's just on stuff
he just thinks different and he's on
stuff if he passed that down to deku
and deku's just running around at 40 for
three seasons
and then he develops his whip ting
that's when i'm like oh
[ __ ] because the super strength point
getting him that no hardly anywhere
and he's kind of is super strength for
the other day what's he going to do with
it he's kind of maxed it out
like he can't really do much if then the
whips team came in
and then they uncovered the fact that
like oh he's got like five more to go
so i can be like oh i wonder what's
going to be next because this this
this super strength thing's played out
then i'll be gassed
but the fact that we know from seeing
what oh my can do
that the super strength alone when it's
100 that almost rocking with
is disgusting a million times better
than anyone else on planet earth yeah
so just getting that one bit that he has
to uh
100 is already gonna make him better
than anyone on the planet
he don't need nothing else and now he's
got five other things that are gonna
happen yeah but can
that just begs the question i can only
only already imagine
well i can't even already imagine the
kind of villain he's gonna face when he
gets to that stage
oh yeah he's gonna the villains are
gonna be on crud different crud
um don't get me wrong he's gonna be mad
and he's gonna have to face up to
all for one at some point and he's
probably gonna have to use all different
[ __ ] to get around mama
because he's got quirks galore um which
is exactly what happened in heroes
peterlee versus my man eventually i'm
pretty sure they all had they both had
loads of different
powers that they were using against each
other i'm pretty sure that's because i'm
pretty sure they had a season where
they went into the future the asian dom
went into the future
and was seeing future peter petrelli and
future whatever isn't cypher whatever
his name is
and they had powers powers kind of rings
the ball i can't really remember
i can't really remember but i think
that's kind of how it went down
um but anyway fun fact
so my fun fact of the day is actually
draws back to i think
episode 98 we did um about the titanic
so there's a guy called um charles
lightler light toller like tulla
he was the second officer of the titanic
he stayed on board until the end and
became trapped underwater
until a boiling explosion set him free
allowing him to escape
and 28 years later at the age of 66 he
volunteered in world war ii
and helped save 122 men from dunkirk
do you think that's world say that again
[Music]
when you say that is sweet speed so he
stayed
onto the he stayed on the titanic and
was trapped underwater until a boiler
explosion set him free allowing him to
escape
28 lit 28 years later after the titanic
sank
and he was 66 and he volunteered in
world war ii
and helped save 122 men from dunkirk
that is that is crazy insane right what
do you mean a boiler exploded and set
him free
i know he must have been his leg must
have just been a bit just a bit tangled
inside
and he's just just saying for a man swam
to the surface
he must have swam to the circle like
everybody else no
i don't know fair play though have you
seen the movie dunkirk
i've not seen it but i know it's a long
thing so obviously in relation to that
does that
sound hard to you in terms of because i
have not seen the moves i don't know
i know it's about a war ryan i think i
know it's about the water i do remember
it a bit
um because i'm getting mixed up with
dunkirk and there's a flipping
19 19 47 whatever it is
movie movie okay say no more um so i'm
trying not to get mixed up between them
too i know
i'm pretty sure tom hardy is in dunkirk
as a pilot
is dunkirk the one where they had like
the longest
bombing thing where the um longest
single shot
where they're just blowing up [ __ ] in
the field maybe bro i'm gonna be honest
with you
i barely remember any of it okay i
remember thinking it was live at the
time okay
but i can't barely remember nothing okay
um
but oh [ __ ] i can't remember anything
about that movie jesus christ i can't
remember anything i've not seen it at
all
um okay never mind but yeah yeah yeah
that as a concept is that he was on the
titanic
swam to safety and then how many years
later
20 28. 28 20 years later
volunteered volunteered to go into the
army and was
just regarded as being a big help in
saving a hundred and how many
22 22 men fair play bros
some man like that oh i don't know man
if i was on the titan obviously we
discussed before if i was on a titanic
and i'm happen to survive
that's my trauma for life fam i'm not
helping i'm not i'm
tired yeah i'm not doing anything that
puts me in danger ever again but i'm
retired
what do you mean volunteering for world
war ii idiot fam volunteering
do you not know i was on the titanic
that would be
my first thing on my cv was on
titan was on titanic survived let me be
fram
was on titanic barely survived
lost two toes bro
don't draft me i'm not going anywhere
don't draft me
leave me be some men have courage bro
bro
leave me out of it different types of
courage i'm just not on stuff like that
me neither volunteer thing is i would
love to this is this whole volunteering
thing
i would love to know what it was like
back then like
um with the patriotism and stuff okay
because these men were so
down well for one
what real fear did they actually have of
losing
because if we have it this way like
i can't imagine that in today's society
imagine them basically saying okay cool
we're going to war with iraq or whoever
we're going to war um england or like
the
great britain is now at war with x
um the army's doing this and we're just
reading and hearing about it like how
the war
in the x is going the war in x the war
and x
all of a sudden all of a sudden
a building over there blows up and
everyone's like what was that
what was that turn on the tv
and then man a basic same war with x
just got real just got very they're
retaliating
we need men
they're retaliating
like i
i don't know
how i would react in terms of i'm
signing up
these [ __ ] these man these men think
they can come over because
back then it was like [ __ ] germany yeah
[ __ ] germany and all german people and
all this i don't know if i have that
kind of hate in me
it's there i can't remember i think the
reason why it was like that back then is
because it was drilled and instilled to
them they had nothing else
not necessarily nothing else to live for
but that's all they were taught from a
young age men go to the war
men fight and then women stay at home
and help the kids and that that was
literally
what was taught to them so i feel like
in terms of patriarchy
back in the day that's why a lot more
men were patriot more patriarchal than
they are
nowadays so i i don't feel like if
something like that happened today i
think i'll be
more frightened than be like oh i want
to fight back
you know that's what i'm saying so what
was going
on back then for them to be like that
bro they were brainwashing these men for
sure
oh hundreds of brainwashing these man's
like you have to fight for your country
you have to fight a country and they
probably
gave them empty promises bro they were
making out like these nazi dons were
like aliens like monsters bro man from
germany are
monsters bro is mad they need to be
stopped they want
because i know propaganda-wise they will
drop in all sorts mm-hmm churchill them
man
they will say in all sorts just they
want ladies yeah they want your kids
dead hitler wants your kids dead
oh my days and this man was sucking it
up but that's the thing is well back
then
people didn't realize that like media
and um government and propaganda and all
that stuff had an agenda
they had no idea that where you get your
news from
may be embellishing something yeah
they just believed they just thought
this is the truth yeah they saw it and
they took it they saw it and was like
that must be the truth yeah yeah yeah
whereas nowadays
if something man blows up cyan and these
men try to tell me
yo country x they want all your youths
dead
they're all extremists and they hate
what you believe in and all this i'll be
thinking
is that true is that true they don't
even know me yeah they're skeptical what
do you mean they want my use there
i don't know there's two sides to this
yeah someone's not telling me something
no i'm not signing up yeah no i'm not
volunteering i already know i'm not
signing up i wonder you're not i'm not
signing up i don't think i would
i know i'm not signing up i got time for
that i don't
think i would but same time i'm trying
to think of what someone could say to me
to make me do it
i don't know what they what what they
would have to say i feel like the same
thing
i feel like similar to probably what was
going on back then
i feel like if people
as a whole are signing up like men women
all's not children obviously but men
women are signing up signing up a
manager's out here dying and we're
losing
i feel like if someone actually walked
at me i was like big man you know we're
losing right
and i was like bro i heard and i said
what the [ __ ] are you doing
what are you doing what are you doing
while you're sitting in this bar like
hahaha
what are you actually doing bro you're
sitting here chilling
man are out there dying you know we're
losing bro and there's man like you
that are just chilling here laughing on
camera
begging three pound here 10p a day here
and there's man out here on the on the
front i hate the time from that line
the man out here that are just risking
it never fully on the front line by the
way
you could never put me on the front line
but anyway continue
i'll be sniper man from disneyland i
will be in the back line
yeah oh no you can never fam i don't
know what
admin needs doing but
sign me up for that sign me up for the
paperwork oh i'm a clerical assistant
whoever needs to get word here there and
everywhere i'll do that that's
me i'll be pinging emails but i'm not
shooting dons
and i'm not being a medic either yeah
but after
wheelbarrow i'm dissing with a curry in
the stretcher thing like that
what is going private ryan i watched
that not long ago
i watched that the second lock down like
mid second lockdown
i hadn't seen the first time the opening
was it the first time you've seen it
yeah oh
wow what an opening scene if you may
have never seen save a prayer right
watch it
oh everyone has to wow bro once i've
found cover
you know when they've made it out of the
water up the beach and they found cover
yeah yeah
i'm gonna tell everyone let's wait till
it all dies down
we're safe now let's just wait till it
dies down
man them were getting shot before they
jumped into the water before they got on
the beach
i'm still getting back sprayed i'm
swimming back
if man in my boat are dying i'm jumping
out and i'm not going towards the beach
i'm going back
you're dying in there bro i don't care i
would rather take my
chances with of open water then i'm
running towards bullets
you got me [ __ ] up
so basically it's peer pressure that'll
make you sign up for the for the army
that's basically what you're telling me
peer pressure and
guilt feeling emasculated oh you can
imagine
what you want when it comes to warfare
i'm not joining i don't care
i don't care bro you can emasculate me
one when it comes out because i don't
care i don't care
human fingers are game out here you
might think life is dead man center for
me unless you think life is a game
you think your man can respawn anytime
no i'm not signing up
would you be a bread that just firms it
and starts learning chinese
once we lose the war
i just did what you said alert chinese
ideas we've lost we've lost
you said so one day you're in there and
you're telling donnie man's in your face
fingers in your face like you lazy
[ __ ] pray useless and you're you tell
them to face big man you can emasculate
me all you want
you man that go fight you think life is
a game i'm not doing that
fast forward three weeks yeah are you
gonna sperm it and learn chinese
i think the only way i would do it is if
let's say for example like germany when
they when they um
germany were like great britain or
whatever when they were taking over
countries they actually took over the
colonizers you know yeah so if china for
example
came over to england and colonized us
and they were about
i'd have to you just sit there and i
think i think i'd have to fair play
to blend in even though i clearly
wouldn't blend in but i'd have to
you know but if they weren't here but i
didn't know but yeah i'd have to i've
got no choice but too
it'll be the hardest thing i ever do but
i'd have to do it
i'd have to blend it would you think it
would you would your mindset be like
well i did say i wasn't fighting so i
just have to um
would you be would you be thinking [ __ ]
i can't believe they're lost and now i'm
stuck here doing this
i think it'll be a mixture of both i
think it'll be a case of one um
vex that we lost even i did nothing to
help it you know
but it's the same way like if you're
watching football you're watching
basketball on your team lose your vex
you've got no choice you've got nothing
to do with it true but that
doesn't have any play on what your life
looks like i know i know i know i know i
know but
i was just trying to give a semi example
yeah um to be fair though
it's similar to being vex about brexit
even though you didn't vote
there we go yay it's similar
a little bit like that like wow we're
actually leaving
that's dead did you vote to stay no i
got bothered
let me get up that morning i didn't get
up that day yeah okay
but yeah um i'll be very indifferent
i'll be vex that we lost even i didn't
do anything about it i'll also be vex i
have to learn chinese one of the hardest
languages in the world
yeah um or mandarin whichever one it
would be
um and i think i would i said
chinese or mandarin you mean cantonese
or mandarin same casualties
yeah that's what i meant you knew what i
meant yeah yeah um
i would be
i don't know i feel like i would never
okay scenario i feel like i'd have to
learn it
but not be able to
let my let's say for example i got wife
and kids
i'd have to i won't be able to look at
it look at them in the eye anymore
with a straight face because they know
i've done far call to help yeah yeah
yeah
they know i've got nothing they've all
survived yeah my wife and kids have
survived but they know i've done nothing
to help
yeah yeah yeah all of a sudden you're
trying to learn chopsticks
affected you facts all of a sudden i've
come home one day
and i'm fluent i'm fluent and i have to
teach these man stuff
they're just going to be looking at me
like you [ __ ] sell out yeah you're
scum
you're are you absolutely you are you're
out here teaching me
chinese because you couldn't be bothered
to get out and fight
they forgive me one day though of course
20 years later when they're still alive
they'll forgive me
yeah one day at that moment in time
there'll be vex like oh dad i can't
believe we didn't fight
now look i'm stuck learning chinese yeah
once they get into
once they start like finding a taste
for like insects and [ __ ] they have a
lot of roaches
caramelized they're actually not that
bad they're first
yeah grasshoppers not bad that's when
they're
like dad i understand i get it now i
understand but when they're young they
won't understand
yeah they won't get it the same way
right i'd round all of them up
that's what i'll do i'll round all of
them up say i've got 10 utes
i round all them up and i pick one at
random
if they start bullying me like you're
nothing brother
what are you doing like you you fully
didn't fire off i swear all right cool
this is when i i will take them i'll
take one of them
all line them all up take one of them
start smacking him
smacking him in front of all of us yeah
i'll say who wants to
who wants to protect him next one comes
in
smacked by the time we get to child
seven
eight or nine they're going to be
shaking yeah they ain't coming in yeah
they ain't coming in for that
and i'm like come then fight what was
you saying
fight perfect example so i don't know if
you saw obviously
um back going back to yours when we lost
the penalties against italy
there was a like a story on twitter he
is a pe teacher
all the kids from these pe class were
vexed about obviously missing the
penalties and they're like all right bet
what i'm going to do is we're going to
actually do it we're going to actually
do a penalty shootout
let's these kids were young they were
like primary school yeah yeah yeah we're
going to do actual penny shot with a
full-size goal post and where the
penalty spot is
and i think there was ten kids only one
of them scored the penalty twenty kids
only one of them scored a penny
and it because they got to the the first
kid got to the penalty spot on four
[ __ ] this is a distance this is a
distance
mama's like oh can we move it a little
bit closer like a little kid he's like
no
you were running out before this is the
real show
show up because he was in goal yeah my
mum was you know he's an adult he's like
27. yeah i guess
he was in goal i'm saving all of that he
was
he was in the works he was doing the
work well he's like oh so
now you get it only one of them scored
now you get how hard it is
and i'm any teacher i'm not some six
four
mvp italian flipping goalkeeper bro
you might have no idea what it's really
like until you're really in it so don't
tell me i didn't do nothing when i when
i didn't want to go go fight in a
[ __ ] war
scum human don't always like being out
there in the trenches
you ain't lived here you ain't literally
you don't know what it's like we
lived you don't always like you don't
know what it's like
bro i've seen it yeah yeah i saw donny's
coming back to work
bus up i'm not going out i'm not coming
out there
oh i've seen the evidence yeah man what
what where's all this pride when i'm six
foot under
you you managed to be you know what so
you man could be there just like oh yeah
at least my dad fought
and we lost anyway no not me cuz
no teach me cantonese
bro teach me the the year of the rabbit
bro
wherever you need to teach me teach me
you're gonna know all the years bro the
sheep the dogs
yeah yeah that's me chinese new year is
a new thing now
bro forget the normal thing gyoza
run that run all of that soy sauce i
bleed soy sauce now
whatever man humana have a clue
oh my god um that's hilarious you said
you had a trash news to you
yes i do actually so there was something
going on on twitter this was a few weeks
ago now
and the subject was what made you
realize
your man didn't love you fam
some of these responses were [ __ ]
gold what made you realize your man
doesn't love you women are sharing
experience their experiences
and stories about when they realize men
hated them and in brackets trigger
warning
so these are just different ones gone
i'm going i'm i'm i'm gassed go on
so i'm not reading that one first that's
too deep
um it's [ __ ] deep that's i'll read
that one like towards the end yeah
all right when he ate nuts and kissed me
just to see what would happen i'm
[ __ ] allergic
just to see what would happen wow
bro and that one's not the deep that's
not the deep one i skipped the deep one
jesus
he cheated various he cheated various
amount of times to the point i wouldn't
have sex with him
after holding out he got so mad his last
words to me were
why would you take away the one good
thing you are for
wow he gave me the clap
while i was pregnant then the side [ __ ]
texted me and said he told me to tell
you sorry
nah that can't be true some of these
can't be true
when i sent him multiple paragraphs on
how much he hurt me
and he was like i knew exactly what i
was doing anyway i just didn't care
[Laughter]
this was the one this was the one this
is a girl right obviously yeah when i
went through his phone
thought he was sleeping then he turned
around and said
after you've finished finding out what
you're looking for go cry outside
[Laughter]
uh
after we had sex for the first time and
my first time ever
he got his bible out and started showing
me scriptures about how it was a jezebel
[Laughter]
i can't breathe this is the funniest
thing i've ever seen
i'm sweating this is the funniest thing
i've ever seen oh that can't be real bro
bro what is this a twitter thread or
something
twitter fed by it i found it on
instagram oh that's the most funny i'm
the funniest thing i've ever seen you
got mad at me every time i had a seizure
oh my god my stomach i'm sweating
oh my god oh some of them are peaked
though
wow all right when he beat me when he
beat me a week before giving birth
i called him to let him know that i'd be
i'd given birth and the baby's not
moving
he said oh so you couldn't give birth to
it was during the hard lockdown last
year and i had to bury my baby alone
in the mortuary fam that's sadistic that
ruined all the laughs that's what i'm
saying some of them are yeah
i couldn't read that i couldn't read
that one yeah that one ruined all the
lights you're sweating you are sweat i
could see it
that ruined all the laughs that one's
harsh
that was harsh there's a couple more
that are too harsh but yeah some of them
are so
funny man said when you're done finding
what you're looking for
go cry outside man said i want a kit
it's the funniest thing it's the
funniest thing
i've ever read funniest thing i've ever
read
but that actually made my abs hurt
after we had sex man pulled out a bible
it said showed scripture of how much it
was a jezebel
it was the first time having said wow
no certain man don't bro the thing is
i'm convinced women are the devil
but some of this certain man just don't
deserve happiness
they don't deserve happiness oh they
don't deserve anything because that
oh my god that's out of order oh my god
i had to get that out
some of those were too funny oh wow
wow
jesus christ speaking of yeah
the difference i realized recently the
difference between men and women
okay so have you ever watched line of
duty
of course i've seen them all okay gang
okay gang so
i watched the first three seasons and
then fell off i don't know why i just
fell off
so i've been trying to catch up so i'm
watching season
five i think i think that's the latest
one or is it season six season six is
the latest one i'm watching the one
with the uh the mixed race woman um
she's the police officer and balaclava
man
and um she's she murdered the forensic
guy and she's trying to cover it up kind
of yes she has that scratching around
that got
ridiculously infected so is this
is this the season where uh maybe season
four i can't remember there was a like a
murderer in the yard and she had to go
back to the yard to
try to clean up some evidence yes yes
yes yes yes yes yes yes
okay so there's a scene right so
basically for context
like i've said she's she's murdered
a guy she went to a guy's yard she's
murdered the guy
and all this and
before she left her house she turned off
her phone
left the phone at home and before she
went to the guy's yard
the husband saw her leave
saw that she'd left her phone realized
it was off
and followed and said that's suss
followed her
i don't remember any of this by the way
that's great for me so he followed her
he saw her going in into some flats and
then
he left he saw go in there and was like
wow she's a cheat
left or whatever yeah rings a bell yeah
so a couple weeks down the line and
stuff like that it all comes out that he
knows that she went out
and was acting dodgy yeah yeah yeah so
he says to her
waguan like tell me everything like were
you are you sleeping with someone all
this stuff because like etc etc etc
and um to obviously
what she actually did is way worse than
ever sleeping with someone
so um she said yeah
i slept with someone it was a one-night
thing i don't love him he's married as
well it was a one-night thing we've
locked it off
everything everything and at first he
was like
sandy newton dandy i think that's her
name i don't know bro i think
that's but continue sorry um so
danny nelson she she was i'm sorry i
love you
it's not going to happen again so yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
not going to happen again etc etc then
a couple days later man was adding a few
more pieces together
he's heard about the murder all this
stuff he knows the area man said
i know you said you were cheating and
whatever but i don't [ __ ] believe you
something's going on cuz you've got this
thing on your arm that's infected
you're not getting it looked at all this
stuff all this stuff
like i don't care i think you're lying
bro like you you weren't cheating you
were doing something
else chat to me so she was like
all backed up and i was thinking that's
the difference in men and women
how so a man a man
if you think something suspect you can't
just tell them i was cheating
and then that's the end of the story man
will think this doesn't add up
regard i don't care what you say this
doesn't add up a woman
as soon as you say you were cheating
this done if you tell a woman if she
says bro
this this or this i followed you this
happened this happened if you just come
out and be
like i'm sorry i cheated she blocked a
[ __ ] note i
knew it i knew it i knew i knew i knew
it bro i could be laying in a bathtub
full of cocaine and unmarked bills
[Music]
blood all over my face she'll bust
through like what the [ __ ]
is going on i could say i cheated and
she said pam
i [ __ ] knew it once a cheat
always a cheat i should have listened to
my mom i should have listened to my
girls i should have listened to everyone
they all said you were nasty
i knew you was a cheat sitting here
cocaine on my bills bro you're a cheat
you're a dog who's this for who's this
for yeah this must have got all this
from your other [ __ ] oh my god
bro women all they want to hear is that
you're a cheat that's all they want to
hear the argument's done
the thing with okay i'm about to spit
some truth for
for the men and women when it comes to
cheating obviously
i've cheated in the past that is it's
stuff that men have done you and women
women do it too i think we're gonna do
it more cleverly as well
um but when okay there's two types of
cheating
when men cheat just for sex
you need to understand it's nothing to
do with you as like let's say my woman
or my partner
like it's just it's just sex and that's
what moment don't understand it's like a
handshake yeah
i don't remember it's literally like a
handshake it meant nothing nothing women
don't understand that
we literally saw something we liked we
wanted to [ __ ]
we bust on that and we got the [ __ ] out
of there you know that's all it was and
more time it was an away game anyway
so when you think uh when we say oh it
was just a one-time
thing and we we [ __ ] up like we
genuinely mean it you know
yeah yes we [ __ ] up but we generally
mean it like we [ __ ] up and it was
just a one-time thing
it has nothing to do with you it has
nothing to do with her i don't fancy or
like or think she's attractive
it it was just a nut you know and
the only difference is is once you [ __ ]
a chick
let's say you've got a mrs and you [ __ ]
another chick and after you bust your
nut
you're all cuddly and like coat in the
same bed that's another thing that's
emotional
yeah what's that about that's exactly
that's a different thing that's when
he actually doesn't give a [ __ ] about
you oh yeah then he's a bastard
exactly which makes no sense as i'm
saying it unless you're a man
unless you're sure that makes no sense
because the act of sex
isn't the bad thing it is bad but it's
not the bad thing
it's the act after the sex if you're
chilling with them together getting all
righty dog and all cuddly
that's unacceptable yeah you know as
crazy as it sounds women
yeah it's the aftermath that's
unacceptable because the sex is just sex
bro i was listening to a pod on your
point literally the other day
where one guy was talking about his
brethren who's a gay guy
and he's very intriguing off the jump
bro he's a gay guy yeah and he goes to
he's on grindr galore okay glory holes
yeah bingies in the flipping hey guys
lavish but when it comes to sex then
manipulation
bro he just goes out frees the app meets
someone in a random toilet
bangs or gets his dick sucked and then
carries on with his dad
and he's in a relationship with another
guy yeah so
um the guy on the podcast asked his his
gay friend like oh
what about your boyfriend doesn't care
about his stuff because he knows what
it's about
we don't talk about it but he does his
thing i do my thing like it's just sex
like it's nothing like i'm in a
relationship with my man like it's
nothing like that
i'm just kidding i'm just getting head
in sainsbury's like
it's not a thing like that i love him
get me
some any i'm just getting skull in
tesco's bro
in carphone warehouse yeah
we love each other bro that makes so
much sense
it makes sense to us so much literally
down the pod was like that makes sense
because you're both guys he literally
said oh that makes sense because you're
both
guys you get it you understand it's just
it's nothing
it's a handshake bro it's a spud it's a
spud it's a quick nut
and it's gone do you know the other
fascinating thing about what you just
said when you said oh he's just a granny
just feels really just
like a thing you can never convince a
woman let's say obviously tinder for
example or bumble all these other apps
when it's um heterosexual it's hard to
just be like boom i just want to [ __ ]
you so let's do this thing
because women take that so offensively
but you're on tinder big man you're not
here to match make
we're not here for that you know you're
not here for that i know i'm not here
for that
why are you playing these games you
don't put these things in your body
it's a weird one because you can say you
can say like if you jumped on and
said like after jump look i find you
attractive you you match with me i'm
assuming you find me attractive
i'm just looking i'm just looking for
physicality my g
i'm looking for skin on skin are you
down they like you said they will get
so offended they're so offended but if
you didn't say that
and you did the dance for half an hour
bro
you can find out so we like so what are
you in here for yeah oh to be founders
on here for a bit of fun
okay so if i ask you what you're on here
for
an hour 45 minutes into a conversation
you're going to willing to be honest
that you just find
for a bit of fun but if i came from the
jump and said i'm looking for fun
i hope you are too if that's the case
then let's have some fun you're going to
be like you're going to think i'm a
piece of [ __ ] yep
but if i do a fake dance for half an
hour then all of a sudden i'm not a
piece of [ __ ]
i don't can't be asked yeah bro bro that
sigh is enough don't don't even try and
justify myself just sigh
and let's leave it there i'm fed up
bro hey guys i'm good gay guys are going
to have made they got amazing
um i have and am i the [ __ ] gang hit
me
okay cool this one's juice so
am i the [ __ ] i've been chatting with
one girl for about two months now
at the beginning we were vibing nicely
and then managed to set up a date
nice on the day i had booked a hotel
because i wasn't gonna drink and drive
oh my god uh he said for context he
lives in newton and she lives in croydon
in london
that's a trek croydon's the bottom
bottom of london is it south okay dead
that already did that
[ __ ] after dropping off some stuff i
went and linked her and we had a good
time watch the movie had some food and
drinks
uh good vibes i managed to sweetheart
talk her back to my hotel
and not long after stepping in we
started getting into it
i'm gonna put a quick pin in that yeah
little pause
just to let my man know you didn't sweet
talk her into nothing
the poems was fresh no waxed
manche think about that the legs were
shaved and
she was getting she knew she was banging
she didn't sweet talk her into [ __ ]
she was three steps ahead of you wait
all of a sudden you had to charm her
into the yard but all of a sudden soon
she got in she's necking off
she's down come on bro don't be naive
we've been there too
but just learn like yeah yeah you didn't
speak talk her into nothing we wouldn't
know when they're banging yeah she knew
she knew she knew
uh anyway uh once all was done we both
just knocked out next morning we go our
separate ways we keep in touch
but then she started uh to call and try
facetime me randomly
at the beginning i made it clear i was
just looking for something casual but
she's not hearing it
um so am i the [ __ ] for blocking her
and deleting her number
um
it's kind of double-ended purely because
like you already said
she already knew she was gonna smash
because the thing was waxed the thing
was clean off
as soon as it got into the dunya they
were lips enough so she knew she was
gonna bang
regardless of this hotel team or not
regardless of this him saying oh i
booked a hotel because i didn't want a
drink
no she knew she was gonna bag yeah the
annoying thing is that
yes he made this effort and even though
yes she knew she was gonna bang
i think blocking and deleting is
it might be a little bit extreme but
then again i don't know how she took the
first initial conversation about
big man i'm just here for fun yeah and
so i'm intrigued to know what her
response was to that
before he blocked yeah
and also did you say you need to like
did you make it clear that the reason
you're having to remind her of this is
because she keeps facetiming you
randomly
big man first off don't ever facetime as
soon as you said that i i was thinking
this is james's pet peeve
bro so when i read it my initial thought
was now you know [ __ ] bro
i would have blocked her immediately
don't ever facetime me out the blue
i shouldn't even have to tell you don't
do it
are you mad are you off your head
facetiming me out of nowhere
who are you now bro that's it might as
well knock on my front door
don't do it do not facetime or call me
out of the blue unless you're my wife
yeah that's hilarious oh my brother
or my mother i know what you're really
you're my best friend don't
ever facetime me out of nowhere don't do
it yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah [ __ ] so i when i read
that i thought i feel that one bro
i feel that one um but anyway
yes we need to know the details between
first of all
what happened between you said how did
she take it when you said look i'm
looking for something casual
and um between the blocking between that
and the blocking and also
when you said i'm looking for something
casual did you say that whilst on
facetime to her
or did you say look i know we had a
great time etc etc
but i don't really do this whole like
talking on the phone facetime thing
it's not really me i'm looking for
something casual if that's how the
conversation
went and then she said oh yeah i get
that and then kept facetiming you then
obviously blocker is crazy i think
that's how he wants
us to feel like that's how he what's
what he wants us to believe yeah yeah
yeah yeah but he also doesn't want to
lie
yeah so he left out a few areas yeah
yeah yeah he left out a few gray areas
you might think you're smart yeah yeah
yeah you might think you won't you might
think you want to unveil the whole
ticket yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah he must
try to play puppet master
he wants us to do his little dance we're
on to you bro
you left out some crucial details i have
a feeling man answered that facetime
rags he was laying on his bed legs
kicking behind
mom's like this fam when you say
lexington behind sorry to come off this
already stick yeah i was eating pum one
day right
if you tell me your legs are doing this
i'm gonna smack you i was eating pot one
day right
and you know when you're just into it
you forget about everything yeah but
then i remembered
because she was lying down obviously i
was so this is her
this is me so her vagina said this is me
ma'am my legs were up
and i just got a brain wave like [ __ ] my
legs are
giddy i need to br like a dog wagging
his tail you're just there
nah i was like where am i i had to
i had to bring myself back to
consciousness and i dropped my legs
obviously she didn't know so i was like
as soon as you said that it reminded me
of that that's the funniest thing ever
family
that's the funniest thing i was i was
like in bed like this you know when
you're just
your feet are just just kicking away
like a school girl wow
oh wow you were lost in them i was
lost in the sauce
that's embarrassing if i would have
walked in by accident and seen your legs
kicking like that
i would have shot you with a nerf gun i
think
the thought of being clocked like that
brought me back to life oh yeah you know
yeah yeah because obviously when i have
sex i'm not i'm not i'm not in the room
yeah
yeah in the sex that's that's what i'm
like when my back is arched and my ass
is up like this
when i'm eating and then i know my
cheeks are here and my hips are just
this just look at that spongebob i'm
just breathing
now that's mortifying
bro that's more i remember we said that
one thing before between the arseh
i'm pretty sure a girl commented one
time saying that she's clocked it before
and just laughed
in her head though she let me carry on
laughing ahead which in some ways is
worse of course
i'd rather you laugh and i'd be like
what's so funny like your ass is just
out then i'll say yeah that's
embarrassing rather than
you're thinking you just let me carry on
you just let me carry on oh
nah that's humility i was a millionaire
i was done
that for like split two three seconds i
was thinking what am i doing
what and the thing is in the grand
scheme of things
it doesn't matter of course not but the
the way i thought i
looked mattered a lot yeah yeah yeah
yeah of course and it was just like
of course of course of course [ __ ]
there's been a lot of times i've been in
that situation where i think if someone
wants to just walk in by accident now
and see me and the most annoying thing
about it is that
the positions i put myself in whilst i'm
eating pum unknowingly
are [ __ ] comfortable of course they
are i'm just very comfortable someone
there on my knees
so sometimes i'm there and i'm on my
knees and my legs are spread apart like
a yoga position
like a child's pose yes fam like i'm
about to get inserted yes
that's how i look it's comfortable a
nice stretch in the groin
everything you think it's above canal
too yeah yeah
i feel like my legs are in stirrups i'm
just there yeah
i'll just flat on my stomach head down
arse up
it's comfortable but ma'am can't
walk in on me like that the streets
can't see that
because it's one of them things
it's one of them things right where if i
was in a girl's yard
in that position eating pum and her
homosexual roommate
happened to walk in and i didn't notice
i don't have an argument if he decides
to get his arms off
and jump in i don't have an argument
because he sees me
that's what i'm saying i'm looking in
that position comfortable i've been
there before
if you want to get invested in argument
i wouldn't have a leg to stand for this
was fists would fly
if he decides to secure my hips nah
i could go next to stand up literally
you wouldn't you literally wouldn't
a man grabs your hips and it raises you
so you're off ground you're eating put
when you're off the ground
he's well barrowed you bro he's will
barrow
you'd never hear us scream the pitch i'd
let out there
my legs would be kicking he better hope
he's strong
strong because i will be fleeing fam
nah the picture would be dog whistle
pitch scream yeah
i could imagine bro i could imagine it
would ruin the whole thing oh of course
it's a fight
but i'm saying yeah in that position i
wouldn't be surprised
i wouldn't be surprised if i'm like yo
big man what are you doing and he said
fam
are you mad i walk in there have you
spread up arch everything
i can see you your whole everything that
balloon knot is
asking for for a treat
you're seeing how you aim us looking
hungry oh my god
and you're vex at me uh you're the
problem yeah you're the issue bro fix up
your posture
what's wrong with you oh bro that's
hilarious but where you're at
what was he back to my man i think you
know we basically got to the point where
he's only an [ __ ]
if he didn't make himself clear enough
yes um
and we need to figure out how crazy she
was or how she reacted
to him saying i don't like you
facetiming me and if she continued to do
it after he
laid the law then obviously the the
block is uh justified
but if you left that detail out and then
just blocked it then yeah you're the
[ __ ] yeah that's as basically as
easy to get agreed um but guys
we're moving towards episode 200 now
that's one in the bag 99 to go
um have a great week we love you
[Music]